I firmly believe that if the white
person is your problem
only the white person can be your
solution and so this is made for you my
white brothers and sisters to increase
your level of understanding so that you
can increase your level of compassion
and lead ultimately to change so
consider this a safe space to answer so
many questions that is former NFL player
in manual macho and his widely shared
social media video it's called I love
this title uncomfortable questions with
a black man part 1 in it he answers
questions from white friends about black
people Oh Cho also talks about white
privilege and why some people riot has
been viewed listen to this around 7
million times on Instagram alone Wow
Emanuel Oh Cho joins us from Austin
Texas good morning to you I just have to
say this Emanuel I love this video I
love the tone I love your energy
I love your candor I don't know you but
I love everything about what you're
doing starting with this you just said
it I'm a big fan big fan if the white
person is your problem then the white
person is your solution how so yeah I
perfectly believe that right now
black people african-american we have
been pleading out for years for hundreds
of years for help
but ultimately the white person our
white brothers and sisters they are the
ones who were in power they are the ones
who truly run this country from being
honest and so I realize it's not
necessarily about what I know Gail it's
about what I can get my white brothers
and sisters to know and if they want to
stand with us which so many of them
desperately want to do at this point in
time well then let me help educate them
Gail let me help increase their level of
knowledge so they can fully feel our
level of pain so they can fully help
well I'm curious Emmanuel how about how
this came about because I don't know
about you but I've had so many white
friends and colleagues Emmanuel I even
heard from someone in high school and
it's been a minute since I've been to
high school asking what can I do to
support yeah you don't need to laugh at
that you don't need to laugh at that so
I'm wondering are you are you getting
the same thing
how did this come about I so it came
about in the crazy way on Thursday I
realized maybe God put me in this
position for now I went to an a
predominantly white private school in
Dallas Texas but I played in the NFL and
way different cultures and I said I know
how to communicate with these white
brothers and with these white sisters
and so Galle I I called up a studio
space and I just ran up the space and in
one take Gail I I opened up my eyes and
I just started talking I never cut the
camera never halves and I just poured
out my heart I realized Gail that white
people predominantly have four questions
that I hear a lot why do y'all think
white privilege privilege exists why can
black people say the N word but white
people can't what about black on black
crime are we paying no attention to that
and why are you alright again Gail I
just wanted to address all the questions
that are uncomfortable for so many of my
wife first yeah yeah but but this is the
thing you say whiteness can be
weaponized I really like what you said
about white privilege and the analogy
that you made and you gave some very
specific examples in your life about the
mailbox talk about that about the
elevator can you talk about your
definition of that it was really well
done
so I preface with this white privilege
is not saying that your life hasn't been
hard as a white person white privilege
is simply saying your skin color it
hasn't contributed to the difficulty of
your life I talked about as a black man
living in an affluent neighborhood in
Austin when I pull up to a mailbox if I
see a white person walking up I will
consciously sit in my car because I
don't want to make her feel like I'm a
threat if I'm gonna if I'm in an
elevator deal with with a white woman or
white man I'm gonna push the elevator
button first and I'm gonna get off the
elevator first in a rush because I don't
want them to feel like I am a threat and
remember Gail Amy Cooper last week the
white woman in Central Park who called
the cops on a on a black man who was
threatening her life when obviously he
wasn't I'm reminded of 1955 Emmett Till
the 14 year old boy who was mutilated
lynched and murdered because a white
woman claimed he he flirted with her
well in 2017
white woman to recanted that story the
two white men who murdered him until
they got off because they knew they
couldn't be charged again due to double
jeopardy they got off and they admitted
that they did it so I say this Gail
imagine if camera phones didn't exist
imagine what would have happened not
just a sense I don't want to imagine but
even today yeah yeah so that was why I
had to inform and I wanted to inform
Gail my white brothers and sisters like
look don't feel guilty don't feel bad
but if you want to step into this fight
if you want to be the solution to this
world peace that we need just simply
educate yourself yeah Emanuel it's
Anthony Mason I wanted to jump in with a
question by the way I'm stunned that
this is still happening even with camera
phones you'd think that that would help
stop at people knowing they're
photographed but I want to turn to a
story about NFL superstar Drew Brees was
being criticized by his teammates for
comments that he wouldn't support any
player taking a need during the national
anthem first I want to play breezes
comments and reaction by his teammate
Malcolm Jenkins let's let's take a
listen I will never agree with anybody
disrespecting the flag of the United
States of America or our country I think
what you do by standing there and
showing respect to the flag with your
hand over your heart is it shows unity
it shows that we are all in this
together we can all do better and then
we are all part of the solution
Newbery's if you don't understand how
hurtful now insensitive your comments
are you are part of the problem no step
off the sphere and I take my helmet off
I'm a black man walking around America
and I'm telling you I'm dealing with
these things I'm telling you my
communities are dealing with these
things
and your response to me is don't talk
about that here this is not the place
she where's the place drew this morning
breeze issued a lengthy apology for his
comments saying it breaks his heart to
realize how much pain he has caused he
added quote I recognize that I am part
of the solution and can be a leader for
the black community in this movement
Emanuel what's your reaction to all of
that well let me set the record straight
my friend Anthony because the agenda
with Colin Kapernick got moved colin
kaepernick at first was told to take a
knee by a green beret a man by the name
of Nate Boyer who I actually played
football with at the University of Texas
he served in the military for over a
decade and continues to serve so for
those that don't know that's just a
quick fat check
Colin Kaepernick wasn't the one who
initiated taking Denis Colin Kaepernick
was sitting a former military person
Nate Boyer told Colin Kaepernick it
would be more honorable to take a knee
I'm disappointed in Drew Brees I played
played with Malcolm Jenkins with the
Philadelphia Eagles I know Malcolm
Jenkins heart Drew Brees has to
understand how can you tell they pressed
person went to protest oppression that
does not make sense to me Anthony that
that in and of itself intrinsically
defines the fact that oppression exists
I am going to tell you when you can
protest your mistreatment that to me
does not make sense so drew Brees I
would hope that he would be somebody who
would watch one of the videos that I put
out and just learn more before you speak
because this isn't about disrespecting
the flag this never was about a flag
this was about awareness right Emanuel I
hope I hope everybody watches your video
by the way of every color thank you so
much for being with us today Emanuel
ah-cha we appreciate it